[Music]
foreign
Adele is making dreams come true the
singer came across a newly married
couple Gabby and Evan still wearing
their wedding attire during her Las
Vegas residency show over the weekend
and gave them the best wedding present
ever the happy couple shared the special
moment on Instagram where Evan is seen
pulling out a marker and handing it to
Adele while she is belting out when we
were young
[Applause]
[Music]
uh yeah assigned wedding dress from
Adele will definitely make your wedding
day a memorable one Gabby reveals in the
caption that she's been dreaming of this
moment for a long time writing quote my
world is made found the love of my life
and this man was determined to have
Adele sing at our wedding seven years
later all our dreams came true thank You
Adele for creating the memory of a
lifetime for us